this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in
a bit when it comes to judging a person
by their legacy things are seldom black
or white
in other words few people can be
considered purely good or unequivocally
evil Andrew Carnegie was a man of
paradoxes he was a businessman first and
foremost and oftentimes this meant that
someone else had to pay the price when
he made his fortunes
although publicly he champions the
welfare of his employees the working
conditions in many of his factories and
plants didn't exactly match up with his
touted values on the other hand Carnegie
donated almost his entire wealth to
humanitarian causes not to mention the
fact that his actions set the trends for
all other billionaire philanthropists
who followed therefore it is up to you
to decide where exactly his legacy sits
as today we are going to take a look at
the life of the industrialist Andrew
Carnegie
you
right off the bat we should have a quick
talk about Andrew Carnegie's last name
ins the fact that most people pronounce
it wrong as they spokeswoman for the
Carnegie Corporation of New York
specifies he was Scottish so the correct
pronunciation of his name is Carnegie
and not Carnegie as most people say it
now that's out of the way let's look at
Carnegie's early years he was born on
November 25th 1835 in the town of done
for mill in the Scottish County of Fife
to William and Margaret Carnegie he had
a younger brother named Thomas he would
go on to play a vital role in the
family's business interests until he
died of pneumonia
at just 43 years of age Carnegie had a
modest upbringing as his father was a
handloom Weaver his first time consisted
of just one main room and designed a
cottage which the Carnegie's shared with
another family at the time of Andrews
birth donphan line was quite famous for
its production of high-quality linen
this created a demand for will
Carnegie's services which allowed the
family a brief respite from poverty and
after that they were able to move to a
larger house this did not last long
though and soon enough things became
worse than ever the Industrial
Revolution brought with it steam-powered
looms which made hand Weaver's like well
Carnegie obsolete during the 1840s
Andrews father joins chart ISM a
political movement which sought to
improve conditions for the working class
the main goal of Chartists was to obtain
universal manhood suffrage all men would
have the right to vote which
theoretically would allow the masses to
take over the government's from the
aristocracy will and his father-in-law
Thomas Morris and actually became quite
prominent members and were heads of the
Chartist chapter in done firm line
regardless that movement was struck down
in Parliament and eventually a faded
away it makes it even stranger that
Carnegie would go on to crush unionizing
efforts later in life given that his own
father campaigned hard for better
working conditions in 1848 there were
few prospects left for the Carnegie
family in Scotland Margaret Carnegie had
tales of a better life in America from
her sister who had already moved there
the family sold all of their positions
and secured a lone Duke a passage on a
ship from Glasgow to New York it was a
long miserable trip where the poor
passengers were packed in the cargo
holds like sardines those who did not
become sick from the terrible conditions
had to work on deck as the ship's crew
was on
and but the voyage ultimately ended
successfully there was no immigration
station on Ellis Island yet so the ship
disembarked somewhere in lower Manhattan
and the Carnegie's continued their trip
west until they reached their final
destination of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
the Carnegie family settled in Allegheny
City a municipality next to Pittsburgh
which would get annexed a few decades
later 13-year old Andrew needed a job
and he found one as a bobbin boy at the
same cotton mill where his father was
employed he had to work from sunup to
sundown made just one dollar and 20
cents per week but kamiki later said in
his autobiography that none of the
millions he made later gave him such
happiness as his first week's earnings
he was now a breadwinner for his family
Carnegie soon moved on to a new job at a
bobbins manufacturer where he made $2 a
week he then became the boss's clerk
because he had nicer handwriting
later his uncle found him a better job
as a messenger boy for the Telegraph
service which paid two dollars and fifty
cents per week working as a messenger
allowed Carnegie to meet many of
Pittsburgh's most influential people who
often received urgent news from outside
the city Andrew excelled at his job
though he was promoted to telegraph
operator a few years later in 1853
Carnegie made another career switch and
went to work as a clerk and operator
that Thomas a Scotty was then a
superintendent with Pennsylvania
Railroad but well later become the
president of the entire company the next
few years saw ups and downs for Carnegie
his father passed away but in 1859 he
was promoted to superintendent when his
mentor Thomas Scott became vice
president of the Pennsylvania Railroad
company he now had a salary of $1,500 a
year
Scott clearly took a liking to Carnegie
who he referred to as my boy Andy and
not only taught in the ins and outs of
business but also enabled him to make
some serious money for the first time
one day Scott approached Carnegie and
asked him if he had $500 to buy 10
shares of Adams Express stock because it
would provide him with a nice return
this information was of course obtained
through insider trading but they went
that fast about it back then
Carnegie didn't have anywhere near that
son but his mother mortgaged family hi
and he made his first investment soon
afterwards he received an envelope
addressed to Andrew Carnegie Esquire
from the Gold Exchange Bank of New York
it contained a check for $10
representing the monthly dividend on his
investment it was the first time that
Kannagi had made money without having to
work manual labor for it
he saw that cheque as the goose that
lays the golden eggs
Carnegie became involved in more
business ventures most of them railroad
relators he mess with Theodore T
Woodruff the man who invented the
sleeping car he was impressed with the
design and brought it to the attention
of Scott and the Pennsylvania Railroad
company presidents John Edgar Thomson as
a reward rudra offered him an eighth
interest in the venture
during the American Civil War Thomas
Scott was first appointed as Colonel of
volunteers and then Assistant Secretary
of War
Carnegie of course was right there
behind him as his second-in-command his
main duty was to ensure that the
railroads and telegraph system were
maintained in working order for the
Union Army at the outset of the war
Carnegie took a trip to inspect the main
telegraph line to Washington at some
distance from the Capitol he noticed a
few wires which have been pinned down to
the ground using wooden stakes
he went to removed the stakes not
realizing that the wires had been pulled
to one side prior to being pins and were
taught they flung upwards violently
hitting Carnegie in the face and cutting
a huge gash on his cheek he later joked
that he was among the first to shed his
blood for his country during this time
Carnegie also got the opportunity to
meet President Abraham Lincoln and many
members of his cabinet the later wrote
with great esteem about Lincoln whom he
considered an extraordinary man he
mentioned that the president's always
had a kind word for everybody even the
youngest messenger boys Carnegie
describes Lincoln as one of the most
homely men he ever saw when his features
were in repose but that when animated
intellect shone through in his eyes to a
degree never seen and any other now
before we get into the man of industry
that Carnegie becomes you can become a
person of Industry yourself with today's
sponsor Squarespace if you've got an
idea for something maybe it's a business
or maybe it's some other venture like a
podcast or a website or a youtube
channel well you should absolutely get a
website for their venture so you can get
that dream out into the world
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to like I said if you've got a business
Squarespace have store functionality so
that you can sell things so if you want
to do a podcast
well they support that too or maybe you
just want to share your thoughts through
a blog of course that's also supported
on Squarespace it all starts on
Squarespace with a beautiful template
that you can customize to your heart's
content or you can start from scratch or
move over an existing domain making
everything super easy to manage don't
start from scratch though I'd use one of
these templates unless you're really a
master of design and once you've gone
through the super easy customization
process
there's no updates there's no patches
there's no technical stuff that you need
to deal with and if you get stuck at any
point you can just get in touch with
that 24
seven support who will absolutely help
you out just at the squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash bio graphics and you'll save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain and let's go back to Carnegie
[Music]
just because he was involved with the
war it didn't mean the Carnegie stopped
looking for new business ventures if
anything this new experience revealed to
him the industries which he believed
would flourish in the years and decades
to come
first he invested in an oil company at
the right time and this quickly yielded
huge returns which provided Carnegie the
capital needed to start his own
enterprises the up-and-coming
industrialists correctly predicted that
the demand for railroads would only
increase and he wanted to be there to
meet those demands first in 1864 he
founded the superior rail mill and blast
furnaces a company that manufactured
rails
soon afterwards came the Pittsburgh
locomotive works which built you guessed
it locomotives even though Carnegie had
a high-paying job with the Pennsylvania
Railroad Company and the favor of his
superiors he decided it was time to
leave after the war and strike out on
his own he remains on good terms with
them though and secured many lucrative
contracts in the years to follow
in 1865 Andrew Carnegie founded the
Keystone bridge company with his brother
Thomas serving as treasurer it was
followed by several ironworks and plants
steel was the way of the future Wren
Carnegie's mind and indeed it would
become responsible for the bulk of his
vast fortune again having a keen
attentiveness for the future Carnegie
was an early adopter of the Bessemer
process a new way of refining steel from
molten pig on it was cheap and efficient
and allowed for the mass production of
Steel on a scale that was never seen
before
Carnegie invested heavily in this
technique and it paid off big for him as
he became the dominant force in the
American steel industry he also
prioritized vertical integration to make
sure that he controlled companies
responsible for all aspects of a steel
business such as supplying raw materials
and transporting finished goods
[Music]
the steel business made Andrew Carnegie
one of the richest men in the world of
course there were others who looked on
at his Steel Empire with covetous eyes
one of those men was financier and
banker John Pierpont Morgan in 1898 he
bought and merged several steel
producers to form the federal steel
company which by 1900's became America's
second largest manufacturer steal behind
Carnegie's company of course but second
place was just not good enough for JP
Morgan a war was brewing between the two
corporations and Carnegie knew it The
Scotsman believed that he could weather
the storm and successfully drive off the
competition on the other hand Carnegie
was not a young man anymore and had
already been contemplating retirement
for some time the linchpin in this
business venture was Charles Schwab a
high-ranking executive and trusted
advisor of Carnegie he was first
approached by Morgan who preferred an
alliance over a war and then convinced
Carnegie to accept a buyout for his
company the asking price was 480 million
dollars for Carnegie steel a term which
Morgan accepted on the spot with no
negotiation later while talking to
Carnegie the financier half jokingly
said that he would have paid another
hundred million dollars for it the deal
was done in 1901 and Carnegie personally
gained around two hundred and thirty
million dollars from the sale of his
company JP Morgan went on to buy several
other businesses and merged them all
together to form u.s. steel the first
billion-dollar corporation in the world
[Music]
kaneki's Korea might have been full of
twists and turns but his personal life
was decidedly less exciting he was a
bachelor for most of his life allegedly
due to his relationship with his mother
to whom he was completely devoted when
Carnegie moved his headquarters to New
York City the two shared a suite at the
Windsor Hotel even so during the 1880s
Carnegie made the acquaintance of Louise
Whitfield woman who was 21 years younger
than him the industrialist noted in his
autobiography that the more time they
spent together the more he realized that
Louise was the perfect one beyond any he
had met and all the young women he knew
faded into ordinary beings
curiously Carnegie believed that his
vast fortune worked against him
Louise thought he already had everything
in the world while she would have
preferred to be the companion and
constant supporter of a struggling man
mimicking the relationship of her
parents the Year 1886 proved to be
devastating for Carnegie both his mother
and his brother died within a few days
of each other while Kannagi himself was
struggling death's door with typhoid
fever eventually he managed to recover
and Louise's company became the only ray
of hope and comfort in his life Louise
now realized that Carnegie needed her
more than any other man and she became
his helpmate as he described her the two
married on April the 22nd 1887 and went
on to have only one child a girl named
Margaret born 10 years later as is
usually the case with wealthy
businessman Andrew Carnegie's life was
not devoid of controversies after his
brother Thomas died many of his duties
were taken on by Henry Clay Frick and
other industrialists who first founded
his own coke manufacturing company and
later became chairman of Carnegie steel
it seems that Frick was at the center of
all the major scandals which tainted
Carnegie's reputation first was the time
when he and his associates caused one of
the deadliest floods in American history
during the early 1880s Frick founded the
Southfork fishing and hunting Club it
counted between 50 and 60 members who
included industrialists bankers
attorneys and almost all other prominent
men in Pennsylvania unsurprisingly
Andrew Carnegie was one of them at first
the club seemed rather innocuous
just another place where rich guys could
relax smoke cigars and maybe do some
fishing however they wanted their own
private place where they would not be
disturbed to that ends they purchased
the Southfork dam the dam was originally
built by the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania a few decades prior but it
had since been abandoned and switched
ownership multiple times when Southfork
club made the purchase it was still
functional but in a state of disrepair
due to neglect the fact that a previous
owner had removed parts of it to sell
for scrap metal the club arranged for
modifications to the dam but they were
more concerned with making it suit their
needs rather than making it safe they
added a fish screen to the spillway they
leveled off the top to make room for a
road and most importantly they lowered
the dam by several feet whenever the dam
sprung a leak it was quickly patched up
and forgotten about it was just a matter
of time before disaster struck that
moment happened on May the 31st 1889 the
area had been hit hard by one of the
most powerful storms ever recorded in
the region which saw between six and ten
inches of rainfall in just 24 hours that
morning the club manager saw that the
lake had swollen and was ready to tip
over the dam he gathered some workers in
a desperate attempt to unclog the
spillway which had been blocked by
debris that was caught in the fish
screen their efforts proved in vain
shortly before 3:00 p.m.
the dam breached - sending over 3.8
billion gallons of water to the towns
below Southfork was the first hit but
got off easy because it was on high
ground several towns were affected but
Johnstown was completely devastated in
what was at the time the single greatest
loss of life in American history
according to the Johnstown Area Heritage
Association 2,200 nine people were
killed including 400 children their
bodies were washed away as far as
Cincinnati 400 miles away for the South
Fork fishing and hunting club the main
priority was negating any liability on
their part they used all the money and
influence at their disposal and ensured
that none of them were ever held
accountable by successfully arguing this
it was an act of God people tried to sue
them but they all lost we can't say with
any certainty how much of the blame
should be put on Carnegie personally he
was simply the most prominent member of
the club but that doesn't mean he was
involved with the maintenance of the dam
even so me like all other members agreed
to sweep the whole thing
to the rug and made no mention of the
flood or the club not even in his own
autobiography a recent study from the
University of Pittsburgh Johnstown
confirms what many suspected all along
it was the modifications made by the
club which caused the dam to fail not
the heavy rainfall
[Music]
throughout his career Carnegie liked to
portray himself as a fair employer who
looks after the rights and well-being of
his workers but he didn't always
practice what he preached at no time was
this more evidence than in 1892 during
the Homestead Strike on one side we had
the homestead steelworks part of
Carnegie's steel Empire on the other
there was the amalgamated Association of
iron and steel workers or AAA the most
powerful labor union at the time the
workers organized to strike after their
deal to negotiate a wage increase failed
Henry Clay Frick who was in charge of
operations at the plant wanted the exact
opposite he intended to slash their
wages and more importantly break up the
Union the situation unfolded exactly
like many other labor disputes of that
time the Union went on strike the
company brought in non-union workers and
calls in over 300 Pinkerton agents who
acted as muscle eventually things
escalated to violence and around 10 men
were killed and dozens more were injured
in the end the state militia intervened
and the town was placed under martial
law the situation took an unexpected
turn on July the 23rd when a prominent
anarchist named Alexander Berkman tried
to assassinate Henry Frick in his office
in downtown Pittsburgh
Buckman shot Frick twice and then
stabbed him in the leg several times
despite this Frick survived and Berkman
was arrested
although the anarchist had no ties to
the a a his actions generated sympathy
for freken's turned public opinion
against the Union consequently other
employers refused to hire a a workers
the membership numbers collapsed and
their funds dried out the strike ended
with a huge victory for the
industrialists like with the Johnstown
Flood it is now a matter of debate
how much blame can be placed on Carnegie
he was in Scotland during the most
violent days of the strike in his
autobiography he claims ignorance of the
matter saying that nothing else wind
'red him so deeply and called it the
biggest regret of his business career
however other documents suggest that he
was well aware of Rick's actions and
gave him approval to do whatever was
necessary writing him in a letter that
we are with you to the end
the man who dies rich dies disgraced
those were the words of Andrew Carnegie
expressing his belief that it was the
responsibility of the wealthy to use all
their extra money for the betterment of
society he made this clear in 1889 when
he published an article titled of the
gospel of wealth where he outlined his
views Carnegie was against simply
passing down his fortune to his heirs
because in his experience these heirs
were often self-indulgent or
irresponsible in this regard the
Scottish industrialist put his money
where his mouth was by the time he died
in 1919 of bronchial pneumonia the 83
year old businessman had given away over
350 million dollars of his personal
fortune it was still a rich man when he
died so technically according to his own
words he died disgraced but he made
provisions so that the rest of his
wealth would go to worthy causes his
family kept the property and a small
trust to live comfortably but other than
that everything else was given away as a
self-made man Carnegie wasn't a big fan
of charities for two reasons first he
did not trust those charities would
manage his money well and second he
believed that by just giving money
directly to people you did not enable
them to actually improve their station
in life
Carnegie's biggest passion was education
he set up 3,000 public libraries and
cities all over the United States
Britain and Canada starting in 1883 with
his hometown of Dunn firm line many
other institutions received generous
grants such as various trusts and
universities the Canadian Corporation of
New York received the largest gift of
over a hundred and twenty five million
dollars and they still do philanthropic
work in Carnegie's name to this very day
so to all of these donations make up for
Carnegie's plutocratic policies indeed
is this why he did it in the first place
was he just wanting to ease this
conscious well these are questions we
can impossible answer but we do know
that the actions of Andrew Carnegie set
him apart and make him unique among the
ruthless industrialists of the 19th
century so I really hope you found their
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe
brand new videos four times a week also
why not check out our fantastic sponsor
Squarespace they are links to you below
and as always thank you for watching